while it's true that many movies try to
be epic one movie had the balls to make
that its own title I mean holy [ __ ] the
movie no epic is a family-friendly 3d
animation about this teenage girl who
gets shrunk down to size and now she's
involved in a warren struggle between
good and evil among a civilization
that's you know insects eyes you have
seen that premise before so if a movie's
not gonna be completely original
hopefully it's still cool or dare we say
epic hopefully maybe I actually thought
epic was pretty cool this girl gets
shrunk and now she's involved in the
civilization that's it they remind me of
elves they remind me of elves from LA
clorium they have to go take this pod to
this really wise guy voiced by Steven
Tyler are you not on board already you
should be I said Steven Tyler no
Aerosmith music is the weapon revolution
X many quarters in the arcade yeah but
the Leafman were cool they were awesome
warriors the main one voiced by Colin
Farrell's a badass he reminded me of
cyan from Final Fantasy 6 he's all Noble
he's all in love with the Queens like no
we must do our duty and the main bad
guys voiced by Christoph Waltz which
that's never bad and they're spreading
rot throughout the forest and you're
like oh wait I've seen that kind of rot
I like stuff like that you know over a
movies like oh this is where that kind
of rock comes from all the while I've
been camping or hiking and I've seen
stumps that look like [ __ ] you're like
oh wow termites went to town on that or
did they it was Christoph now I know
that
who says movies aren't educational no
one should it was the cool intrigue and
adventure of another world that takes
place in your backyard I was big honey i
shrunk the kids family I was growing up
what guys it's a simple premise but a
smart one we're normal-sized so we have
our normal world if you get really big
like say you're Galactus or something
you're now in another world you shrink
down to insect size you're now in
another world bad guys are coming good
guys got to stop them it's all up to
this girl to save the universe or at
least a section of the woods in her
dad's backyard it does have a few
touching moments between her and her dad
her and her dad you know they're
estranged because her dad's crazy but
he's not crazy because he was always
like this civilizations out there of
course you were gonna know that the
moment he started talking about it
you're like I've seen the poster I know
he's not wrong the funny thing is if the
good guys in this movie completely fail
the world would be no different to
people we'd all be like okay
have you checked the steam sales today
are they good I'm gonna check them so
groundbreaking no good for kids yes good
for adults yeah if you're an adult who
takes your kid to epic you're gonna have
a good time with it this is a push for
me I'm like good time no alcohol
required I feel like I'm cutting it
short because I actually had a lot of
fun with this movie so I'll say it's a
very strong good time no alcohol
required for all intensive purposes I
walked out of epic saying to myself well
that movie was say it with me now at
least really cool I so epic have you
seen it what did you think and what's
the animation you're looking forward to
this year whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]